il tentait de fuir l'est de l'ukraine
mais l'horreur de la guerre les a
rattrapés en pleine gare de cramât
torche ou ont circulé des milliers de
civils ces derniers jours une effroyable
attaque
j'étais parti acheter des cigarettes
là-bas et la bombe est tombée raconte
cet homme
j'ai vu que ma grand mère était morte
j'ai couru pour aider des gens plus loin
l' attaque au missile a fait des
dizaines de morts et de blessés parmi
les victimes il y aurait des enfants sur
le quai de la gare des corps gisait près
des peluches et des valises tout près
les restes d'un missile où il était
écrit en russe pour nos enfants
il n'y avait pas de personnel militaire
à cet endroit dit le président ukrainien
seulement des gens ordinaires qui
tentaient de prendre le train pour se
rendre en lieu sûr
pendant que la russie toute
responsabilité les occidentaux ont
condamné l'attaqué en bloc le premier
ministre britannique parle de crimes de
guerre
qui ne restera pas impuni
c'est épouvantable c'est horrible un
cauchemar dit la président de la
commission européenne arrivé en ukraine
ursula von der leyen a visité le c2
notre massacre celui de boudhha le choc
pouvait se lire sur son visage devant
une fosse commune
une démonstration de solidarité de la
dirigeante européenne venus discuter
d'envoi d'armes supplémentaires à
l'ukraine
3 et
l'ukraine marche vers un avenir européen
at elle déclaré mais au delà des mains
tendues qui m attend des actions
concrètes comme un embargo européen sur
le gaz russe dans mon prochain nadeau
pour morata
les sanctions doivent être renforcées
souligne le président ukrainien parce
que la russie n'écoute ni rien ni
personne cette nouvelle attaque contre
des civils dans nos tristes aperçu des
horreurs qui pourrait attendre l'est de
l'ukraine si la russie il resserre son
étau elle met aussi en évidence les de
l'indignation exprimée par les leaders
européens et ajoute de la pression pour
des sanctions encore plus musclée contre
moscow ici louis blouin radio-canada ali
vivent en ukraine